[Music]  your presence is requested at the Royal  Wedding of Prince G spent of bendable  and princess B do you take this man to  be your husband  no oh my god this is a bad time to be  coming down off of that high so how'd it  go  I want to be in charge of my own destiny  I want to see the outside world  I want to get rid of all the diseases  plaguing mankind and replace them with  worse ones control I don't even know  what they yell at you I'm not so bad  well you did kill that one guy I'd be  fine if someone could just slide my head  up a bit isn't our point everyone's life  where they need to go and figure out who  they are  look I'm a good butcher this is a pet  shop  what's this fluid I don't want to drink  away that's hope  [Music]  I'm so proud of you I'm elf Oh  remember the trick to not getting swept  over the waterfall is swimming upstream  got it you can do anything if you  believe in yourself  [Music]